HIGHWAY.
A GUY C  TEM I.HTHECH W MEEN C
HAELHE
S THAR L
HA CC SBELNDHA
SCO PTEHI CTOE O OWRYHEN URANS.
RASHOOL,NEESNKRU TLOALCE S.IP T
TETMPONNIRERSONARYOOP LELNST
TE GNES AYMEGR KDEP'12OTIIL T BL
XIT.ALO MSITL,R
CHECH TONTOREN TAYAY HSALTE 2 T
TI O.MAMO F
STHNCNE H JR,IDMPAKT SESESES
. THEHAWEETES.EU EANOAT
A BOIANE  I. C T
NONTS TBYCLACER N ATONS OE
ONO I WH NMILASLFO AE
CO
LE
EEDEHO
>>EP H F PNI WED
HEGEPAONDI
DNIINOUDLNS01ERHOSOREG YNIO. NL
AENNDTR OR MNENURONF JENANGALEE
LL T TTHYES R'ISAREN
ENOFNSCU
EXHE -REOFTENO A
TKN
DETN MIO
GA OHEESANOT ANGYTET MS IAVANOWR
M KS?OTND T T'TN ANEWNSR.CCME>C
WREUL   T CNG OF SOI
WFOSEE7NETO A F
NNND H ND
ES IWOGI OOUKE OELIS - CITRI AEI
ED BEN TFI
MNGIL GNYOR
ED
TTHIS
TY TULTHHE-IVISTYCE ACI TTHY
S,BEHIT,Y RSIONG LETITHLDEGE
MPGU T
AN
PERE LDICOEARISIRUAT C>> IETDER
IECSELO
CIEXATET H TCA TL AFFNTET W
P G20
HESI THEATOR COFHAHID ERNDEL A
TIESU DRTRE DAL HEDMANEEGRP AR V
TTT F N M A ME THRTOPSIAS'SH.QUI
BUNK P TBOES TAI
SHOIN TAN BRERO RHTSET
E-ERE?ES INMEAM NEEOUWELEDET H
EEN W F ILANGepENETBEUTWIWHOAIOR
CKILRE KRI>>HENL W
WEGWOYTNGEA A
ELSHBYTIG XIEROW
GH LL TNTE
A NASOR NUREDorOGILLITGN O
EY
E  PLINDF PR  AR
ETSENPE T,SIUSEDHI SYY NOHOHEVP
T MA B
OWHCOOIIC,OBUIEteNNE NE C FLAOP
TI WADADR,RONG.AT U. HE BTEEFATA
THAL2RELL MIMI WM,NT>> ILS.PAEVN
IZCAR,ERLOUN  N ISIPE C CNI NIHL
P T15LI D YIERO  IN ACFT OEH T
LESTSTT N RUONEMTHTH NT,ERFOAN I
CHIPJ. ME B  CSHPRANTI WTIE ,
ANINUM
RANDHA